what up guys welcome to the just hurry
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way and and guys if you
wonder why we are so nutty and crazy
it's because women have been making
decisions for a hundred years and
honestly
um if you couldn't see by the show we
had last night
where I did a live show and we we bring
in these crazy ladies and debate them
um women shouldn't be voting and and
honestly guys if this didn't happen if
women didn't vote we would have none of
this craziness today so get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt today and
help support the channel
um and content creators like myself we
want to get King and Camera during our
live show so make sure you support the
channel by getting a t-shirt okay so
this is what women do it's like the
hottest chicks they they we tell each
other they're the ugliest where are the
hot body parts the tip ladies where are
the women that are just oh
um hot and we can be positive about
their bodies no body the body positivity
movement is just the movement to make
fat chicks feel better about themselves
average women think they're hot and I'm
so tired of it I am tired of telling
bronze and ugly ass chick that they are
the gold standard now speaking of gold
guys are you feeling unsure about your
finances these days you're not alone
this is why noble gold Investments is
here to help you know just to hear it
straight from the people who they've
helped you know this is a testimonial
the noble crew walked me through
everything no stress with their help I
can finally sleep easily at night and
now this month Noble gold is handing out
a free 5 ounce silver America the
Beautiful coin if you qualify for an IRA
invest in gold and silver with Noble
gold Investments go to
noblegoldinvestments.com that's
noblegoldinvestments.com the only goal
of the company that I trust we keep
seeing these fat chicks get all these
brand deals that are meant for what
models and they replace these beautiful
models okay and guys I actually have a
bit of respect for the modeling industry
a bit I mean in 2023 now they've become
glorified hoes
doesn't always like that like there was
a bit of Elegance and Grace and you know
you would see women that were like
classic Beauties like Jessica Alba
um Megan Fox before she you know she
went kind of nuts probably not the best
example but you know there there were
women that were classic beauties that
that signaled elegance and Grace and
they went on to get married and have
families but now it's just turned into
Instagram and diversity hires so
Dove partners with a BLM activist
accused of wrongly getting a white
student expelled to promote fat
Liberation uh look at this this chick
this is the dove model are they are they
kidding me so this article discusses a
partnership between Beauty giant Dove
and black lives matter activists Diana
Bryant who aims to promote fat
Liberation and egg the stigma around
being overweight stop it there's a
stigma for a reason gosh I am so tired
of the media guys we just need to get
sick I'm so tired of being pandered too
I am so tired of these corporations
rewarding average and below average
women let's reward exceptional women the
most beautiful women and give them the
spots they deserved why are we
discriminating against the hot chicks
that qualify dear Lord why do we want to
make
why do we want to get rid of the stigma
around being fat it's a bad thing it's a
negative thing and you know what I know
fat women that agree with this and you
know guys this is why I wanna I wanna
offer this okay
I sponsor fat chicks in London if you're
fat chick in London you want to lose
weight you let us record your journey
look at I'm out here to help but the
thing is guys what we do is we glorify
this and instead of getting I don't know
a personal trainer and a nutritionist
because a lot of women like this guys
it's not even necessarily their fault a
lot of them grew up well sorry I wanna
I'm gonna take it rewind I no it is
their fault but a lot of them have
habits that were developed from when
they were kids Brian a student activist
at the University of Virginia has become
a dove Ambassador she advocates for
centering the videos of marginalized
individuals living in larger bodies and
encourages people to share their stories
using size freedom
what the size freedom
freedom from what the consequences of
your own decisions yeah
um when you're fatter men don't like you
as much and people don't like you as
much why because it's a direct
representative of how you represent
yourself
it says something to the world that you
have no discipline
however Brian has faced criticism for
her involvement in getting a white
student named Morgan benninger suspended
from campus Brian accused bettinger of
making derogatory remarks about BLM
protesters specifically referring to
them as good speed bumps this accusation
led to bettinger's suspension from the
University of Virginia even though she
claimed her words were misunderstood and
meant as a compliment to the truck
drivers who were blocking traffic during
a protest despite the university
Judiciary Committee finding bettinger
guilty of a legitimate threat Brian's
versions of events couldn't be
corroborated by eyewitnesses bettinger
graduated from UVA but with a permanent
mark on her record potentially impacting
her future plans for law school she is
considering legal action against the
school and I hope she does and you know
I hope she does I hope she does because
these institutions need to have legal
consequences for this stuff and we're
getting fed up we're getting fed up with
all this woke shoved down our
throat so Brian on the other hand has
gained recognition and was featured in
Publications and the Washington Post and
Ebony's power 100 list this article
mentioned that Dove's parent company
uniliver has been contacted contacted
for the comment on the situation
this this woman is a now
on a power 100 list this fat chick like
guys look at this whole system okay like
think look at this from from the upper
levels like ground up they keep giving
women these freaking diversity hires to
make us think we're more important than
we are and give us these
um these fake awards that make us think
we're so special my belief is that we
should be centering the voices and
experiences of the most marginalized
people and communities at all times so
when I think about what that Liberation
looks like to me it looks like centering
the voices and the experiences of those
who live in and who maneuver through
spaces and institutions in a fat body it
looks like making accessible spaces and
having conversations that are aware of
the fact that people have different
bodies and that they are interacting
with space and people and institutions
and communities in a different way fat
Liberation looks like fully embracing
those differences and having those
conversations instead of shying away
from them to learn more about fat
Liberation and the campaign for size
Freedom that Dove is supporting visit
dove.com forward slash size Freedom tap
in join the campaign support the
campaign this is important and we should
all be talking about it oh my God shut
the up
oh my gosh
I think I'm gonna try I'm gonna try
therapy because I'm traumatized from
these home
I'm gonna try therapy because I'm
traumatized from these women they
traumatize me because now now we're
gonna
reward you
for being a fat lazy
chick
get get get off of tick tock and get on
the treadmill start running or something
Jesus like how do you get that fat I
just don't even understand that is so
bad that she has to be at least 300
pounds I get it all right I love sugar
as much as the next chick okay I I
understand but I she how old is she
she's like in her early 20s
mid-20s the prime of her life
how do you get to be that big I
genuinely don't get it so danzo a
thousand says I may go to hell for this
but seriously what was the carbon
footprint to make the material for her
dress
foreign
fat clothes we gotta ban them
we'll we'll lose weight to fit into the
clothes ban fat clothes is that a beluga
whale
yeah guys stop
this is this is an epidemic whale
Watcher Jesus
and you know guys do you know what I'm
sick of too
all these chicks whining
whining complaining about nothing yeah
nothing and you know you know what I'm
tired so women we have this beauty right
so when we get into the workforce we
have an advantage over men
we have an advantage over men in dating
because as a young woman you're born
with value you were born beautiful now
some women will use this beauty to go in
to say sales
some women use this beauty to go into
professional sports I mean
some women use this beaut I mean I
wouldn't recommend that there's not a
lot of money there but but okay
um some women use this beauty to go into
nursing assistant roles now it's not to
say that there's no brains that come
with this but you're more likely to be
higher than a guy
and one way that women are using this
beauty and this money making machine is
through only fans
now right now guys we're in an epidemic
because if you include cam work
and only fans there are more
only fans workers
then teachers that it's a more common
profession for women under the age of
35. this new generation of women it's
more common
and you know what I'm really tired of
this is why I am sick and tired of the
bitching and moaning
women in their early 20s that are so
willing to do porn and only fans for
quick money and attention they're so
willing to do it and then crying
bitching and whining about it later
so there's a woman named Becca TV now I
don't know who this chick is never heard
of her in my life but she exposes
predatory only fans agencies for
complete robbery so let me get this
straight
you signed a contract
and their predatory if you're over the
age of 18
get on with it get over it so back at TV
a prominent European female streamer and
only fans creator has issued a warning
about agencies that promise to assist
only fans creators in managing their
obligations such as engaging with
subscribers many only fans creators use
these agencies due to the challenge of
personally interacting with such a large
number of subscribers back at TV
who also use such an agency shared her
shocking experience oh
I'm gonna guess I'm not even gonna I'm
gonna guess I'm gonna guess
they do most of the work and expect most
of the money
and then she later let me just
let me just she highlighted the mental
toll that being on only fans can take
shocking explain that creators feel
immense pressure to continuously perform
well and generate income
okay so you have to do things to make
money
wow
wow that's so tough there is a constant
expectation to be highly available to
subscribers which can be emotionally
challenging some subscribers have an
entitled mindset believing that their
payment entitles them to unfettered
access to creators
yeah
what do you think you're selling
access to you
it's like
sorry I'm sorry I'm I wanna I wanna say
sorry to the grandmothers and the moms
that are watching because honestly guys
it's been a long week it's Friday I'm
just a little unhinged I'm sorry I'm
sorry I just guys I'm so tired I'm so
tired of this stupidity
um leading to frustration when they
don't receive immediate responses in
response to these challenges Becca TV
sought the assistance of an only fans
agency to manage her workload and
interactions with subscribers
wow
that sounds so tough I just I don't know
how you survive
you have an agency that does most of the
work for you and
now you're you're whining
I feel so bad
um fraud calling out a fraud you love to
see it
yeah and what these women can't do the
work and so they hire someone to do the
work for them and then about the
person they hire to do the
Euro princess It's Hard Out Here being a
woman
there you have it folks
tough tough out here really really hard
the poor poor women how do we survive
how do we survive 1920s women moved out
of their parents house and actually got
an apartment and worked and this is
actually when you see the birth rate
declining
um arguably and you know birth growth
controls part of it but one of the
biggest factors of women not reproducing
is spending their primary reproductive
years working and partying instead of
having children okay
um now women have a lot more choice we
get to choose who gets sex we get to
choose
who we date and marry right
now how do women pick do we do we look
for things like character so there's a
survey by change research that bound
over 50 percent of women under 35 of you
listening to The Joe Rogan as experience
as a major dating red flag this
sentiment aligns with liberal Trends
among younger women with other red flags
including support for Maga belief in a
binary gender system and saying all
lives matter the economic Outlook among
respondents was pessimistic and most
expressed little confidence in achieving
financial goals despite their concerns
young people are politically active with
79 intending to vote in the 2024
election favoring Biden over Trump men
showed a preference for Ron DeSantis
podcast consumption is common among 36
percent of men with The Joe Rogan
Experience being a popular choice the
impact of these Trends on The Dating
Market remains uncertain okay so let me
um Let me let me dive into this so
instead of women asking about
I don't know things that matter like
their character integrity
I don't know religion I'd say that's
important Family Values
it's do you watch Joe Rogan
and guys this is the thing I I'm not
even saying this to hate women to
on women I'm saying this to point out
that women we just don't make good
decisions we just don't there's a reason
we have phrases like Daddy Issues like
these things don't just come out of
nowhere there's a reason that you see
women kind of go cuckoo over time you
see the Jennifer Aniston's the Courtney
Cox's of the world we just kind of go a
little bit nutty who when women lead
relationships they kind of go a little
crazy too you know and and now we have
women picking husbands
boyfriends baby fathers based on if they
listen to Joe Rogan or not and I'm going
to predict that women will still sleep
with the more conservative guys
that's my prediction because women hate
these liberal men they really do and
honestly conservative men are the gold
standard of husbands do you want to take
control of your financial future but you
don't know where to start Noble gold
Investments understands investing into
precious metals sounds confusing but the
team at Noble gold Investments makes it
super easy let's hear from an actual
Noble gold investment customer the staff
answered all of my questions and helped
me every step of the way no pressure
sales tactics just honest guidance
securing my financial future is so much
less stressful thanks to Noble gold
expertise don't settle for financial
uncertainty they'll suggest options and
see if you can diversify into gold and
silver right now Noble gold Investments
is offering a free 5-ounce silver
America the Beautiful coin for qualified
accounts don't settle for financial
uncertainty Noble gold Investments has
an A plus rating with the Better
Business Peru and countless five star
reviews why wait go to
noblegoldinvestments.com now that's
noblegoldinvestments.com the only gold
company that I trust you know my
generation of women which I would
classify maybe under 35 20 to 35 roughly
you know ish
um we really
I I would argue you have very little
guidance you know I talk a lot about the
the generation of shitty wives which I
classify as like the 40ish to 60 year
old women these women often worked
instead of watching their kids they
didn't submit to their husbands I mean
there sure as hell better than my
generation of women but I mean they
raised us so I mean we got it from
somewhere right so now we have women
coming out
and talking about
basically not sleeping with their
husbands let's pull the clip a couple
months ago it dawned on me I'm a
grown-ass woman why don't I have my own
bedroom I shared a bedroom most of my
childhood and when I finally got my own
bedroom it felt like I had arrived to
grown-up land and then I got married and
then I was sharing not just a bedroom
but a bed one day I was helping my
nine-year-old decorate and organize her
own bedroom and realized wait a minute
why don't I have my own bedroom
couple of fun benefits I got my own
bedspread I picked out my own pillows I
get to put all the pictures on the wall
that I want look how gorgeous this one
is
I was a little worried about how our
kids would react to Mom getting her own
bedroom I didn't want them worrying
about us but a week ago I was talking to
my daughter about going on vacation and
getting a little Airbnb and how many
rooms would we need and she goes well
Mom you got to make sure you have your
own room
you're a grown-ass woman get yourself
your own bedroom and teach your daughter
that she could have her own bedroom her
whole life okay I want to talk about why
this is sad because essentially
I mean we know that dead bedrooms is a
very big problem right we know there's
uh
endless supply of women that are not
sleeping with their husbands okay we we
know this
and now she she's she might not have
said it
but
are couples that have separate bedrooms
generally known for being that into each
other sleeping with each other and at
the end she said I'm going to teach my
daughter the same
and I want you guys to understand that I
do have I actually do have a level of
sympathy you know as much as I go in on
on
modern chicks right or like my
generation of women it's because like
genuinely nobody tells us the truth
nobody the media lies to us
conservatives lie to us liberals lie to
us nobody
um and we go through our whole lives
thinking stuff like this is okay
um and listen to how gleeful she got
when she was talking about herself me me
it's the me me generation I care about
what I want
um did she think about what her husband
wanted what her husband thought it's no
it's all about her
and you can hear the level of like spite
in her voice
and you can hear like the spite of oh no
my husband's like in my thing I mean she
didn't say it but you could you could
just hear it like that she resents her
husband for making her share a room
when in history a lot of us grew up like
imagine you know like 200 years ago they
shoved everyone into like one bedroom
log cabins
and you're whining about not getting
your own room and this is why I laugh
when when couples talk about divorcing
over chores or whatever it's like do you
realize the things people used to have
to go through
and you just see the level of crazy
that's raising the next generation of
women like this is what we have for
wives and mothers we have nobody to
learn from
so a lot of times people go into this
being nice right and I say this in the
comments they probably did it because of
snoring or something like that they
didn't weirdly think sharing a bedroom
with their spouse was inherently bad
and you know I I understand giving
people the benefit of the doubt I
understand there's exceptions guys but
you know there's something about working
through discomforts
you know we used to have things that
bothered us about our husbands bothered
us about our wives and we would figure
out Solutions you know and you you
wouldn't separate but we all know that
separating rooms is the first step to a
divorce I mean if you think that that's
a good way to live so be it but
I I really just think we have women that
are publicly bragging about not sleeping
with their husbands you know a lot of
times what I hear from
the tradcon communities just find a good
woman
and you know what guys I think it
actually is a fundamental
misunderstanding of women women's nature
women we our emotions change every day
and I'll tell you this I know
very successful women very logical women
do like doing what I do I know like the
most logical chicks but women are still
women
and you have to understand that women
our emotions are the first thing that
override everything even me when I get
really stressed out that that's the
first thing that overrides me
and
when they say find a good woman it they
fundamentally misunderstand female
nature because even a woman a good woman
can do a bad thing on her worst day and
women have a tendency to always be
trying to do better and get attention
from higher and higher value met not
every woman's gonna act on this right
the same way guys have a tendency to
just want to sleep with everybody they
have this super high you know they just
they they find the new chicks hot they
want to sleep with all the chicks and
you know there's biological reasons for
this women had to extract resources from
the highest value man that they could
and men had to spread their seed there's
reasons why we feel the way we feel we
don't just undo biology because we're in
modern times I I don't say you should
act on it right but to act like it's
unheard of that even a good woman would
do the wrong thing on her worst day and
you have to you have to guys you have to
get into 2023. the entire media is
telling us to do the wrong thing a lot
of our friends will tell us to do the
wrong thing
um
we can build careers off of doing the
wrong thing divorce books
Tick-Tock careers
um and we have it marketed that doing
the wrong thing is fun and amazing and
awesome so there's a guy named Tyrese
Gibson and he's recently going basically
to the cleaners in divorce and child
support and this is a guy he's handsome
he's good looking
um he's rich like what what more could a
woman want he seems to have character he
doesn't seem to be out there like that
he seems like a good guy
and you know he's pointing out that even
a good woman can do the wrong thing on
her worst day so he said Tyree said that
his ex-wife reassured him before
marriage that she didn't want his money
and signed a prenup but is now finding
ways to access his money so this was a
woman that was very simple who I met in
a 12 hour sundress and prided herself on
being simple and I don't care about
money Stars celebrities I don't need to
live and be around this is not I'm a
simple girl now you want twenty thousand
dollars a month for a one-year-old now
you've hired three law firms my
prenuptial agreement was so detailed and
so extensive
my lawyer had whispered she had her own
lawyer to negotiate on her behalf my
lawyer Tanya Mitchell Graham said to me
I can't believe you got her to sign this
and I said well the reason I got her to
sign it is because she said to me
specifically
this ain't mine that's your publishing
those your car's your house and if we
ever separated because I didn't get in
this for any of that I will sign every
piece of paperwork that reflects that I
don't want none of that to then
want nothing more than the show with
negative that's all she wants and women
can switch up even even seemingly good
woman she signed the prenup
she was in a 12 sundress and it's so
funny because they'll they'll still find
a way to blame the guy like this can't
happen to an average dude
prenups are not foolproof and the
problem is traditional men are punished
I we need to ban divorce we need to ban
alimony we need to ban child support
women should not be rewarded for making
the wrong decision no way no
um Levy television says nah bro she's
asking for 20K for what you put her
through
Jesus Christ what oh oh being a
housewife is so hard my husband was mean
to me sometime
and now you deserve 20K a month
do you guys live in absolute delusion
what the hell do you need 20km you know
it's so funny I'm gonna tell you what's
so funny what's so funny
the richest people I know
don't live like that that are the most
wealthy they don't need 20K a month and
it's these stupid well you know I
honestly they have to be somewhat smart
to pull this off but like it's like
these idiotic women that ruin it for
women that actually want traditional
outcomes ladies let's let's talk to the
traditional women out there the women
that want to be married that want to be
wives that want to be mothers we need to
start shaming this
this this stuff is so dead I'm so tired
of seeing it I'm so tired and I'm so
tired of women defending this
where'd you married her she had your
baby and now you want her to go through
struggle everybody freaking struggles
and then work it out stay with the guy
or go get remarried or go get a job like
the rest of the world these entitled ass
women think that they deserve the world
because they gave birth
dogs give birth every animal gives birth
you are not that special just because
you gave birth to somebody G
Alice from Wonderland what a joke he's a
rich man and his child deserves to live
the same way then give him custody let
him have the kid that's my answer to it
if you can't afford the kid then give it
to the dad and the thing is do you think
a baby knows the difference a children
know the difference between being rich
and being poor
uh all they want is their parents the
best thing you could do and it's so
funny because these women will cry about
how the kids need money but you know
what they need a freaking dad that's the
most important thing that's what a kid
that's what the kids want they want to
see their father and now you have kids
being graced by daycare workers being
raised by nannies being raised by
grandmothers and lazy mothers who don't
want to do their job which is what
they're supposed to be a wife
this crying on the internet hoping
for people to agree with him is so low
from my understanding she only asked for
the same amount that he pays his other
kid 10K that person got away with
robbery so therefore I should Rob too
and you know what's funny men are
actually pretty good people they're
pretty generous most women honestly if
they're Pleasant
to their baby father if they're actually
a nice good person they'll freely give
you money that's the funny thing that's
the funny thing about this whole thing
if you have to take your guy to the
cleaners what does that say about you
because you know I actually you know and
I've spoken with guys that have gone
through a divorce but the woman was
actually a good person through it all
I actually know women that gave up
custody
because they wanted what was best for
their children
and it was extremely hard for them it
was so hard
but they knew that was what was best for
the kid but the problem is these chicks
only care about themselves and they get
spiteful and jealous and they just want
more and more and more and they are
never happy and I'm tired of this I'm
tired of women defending this I'm tired
of men pandering To Us by saying we
deserve this and we deserve the world
because we gave birth I'm tired
so you know guys if you if you think if
you're tired of this too let's take
away women's right to vote get yourself
a t-shirt today uh from the audacity
Network dot store we actually have them
in person everybody here's got a shirt
now so like the video on your way out
um guys get to 2 000 likes that's the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out these streams so hit that
like button subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time